[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
there we go glad to have our guests so
this is a long-form interview it is for
now and then it's kind of first twenty20
team first or 2018 the reason is because
we are going to be a bridging attack
February 6th true so we need to buy some
time on the road they're only select a
few people who are worthy of long-form
interviews very very it's a boiler alert
it's not you that's never ma so our next
guest he's been making the rounds and
he's probably as viral right now he's as
hot a ticket has ever been his book is
that of course the 12 rules for life
you've been reading it quite a bit been
reading it I've had to look at the cliff
notes because I have it in my queue
right now I have Erica I think Eric
Metaxas his book on Martin Luther that
I'm finishing and he'll be on the show
too but this is of course by dr. Jordan
Pederson you can also do the self
authoring program if you go to use a
promo code Crowder you get 25% off
because I'm a basket case so it's helped
me so if you're as messed up as me he
can be as useful for you of course he's
on the Twitter at Jordan B Peterson dr.
Peterson thank you for being here sir
thanks for the invitation well no of
course and you knew you were gonna get
an invitation I think you invited
yourself as a matter of fact oh yeah
yeah well yeah it's my live stream yes
exactly
well come on we have some firepower even
if they happen to be some people who you
might not necessarily want your fan base
um so first off this book it's been
selling like hotcakes correct what's
what's the reaction been by and large
and I know there's been viral videos but
the book it's spelt itself what kind of
feedback have you gotten well it's it's
hovering between number one and number
two on Amazon in Canada the US the UK
and Australia and it's the same on the
bestseller lists the big bestseller
lists like the Wall Street Journal and
the London Times and all that it's crazy
it's selling like mad yeah for those who
haven't read it kind of give them
obviously a bit of a summary you know
what's what this stems from what what
kind of data is it is it you know by and
large a big component of or is I should
say maybe the self authoring program a
big component of this book well part of
what the book does what promote is the
idea that you need a vision in life and
a strategy and so that's a good overlap
with the self authoring program isn't
doesn't make
cific reference to the program but it I
would say provides the psychological and
philosophical and ethical underpinnings
for what what we're doing with the self
authoring program and so the idea
basically is is that well that there's
no doubt that life is difficult and that
people get betrayed and that hard things
are coming down the pipeline for
everyone all the time but that if you
organize your life reasonably and face
it courageously and make a plan so that
you're not just a leaf in the wind and
try to do things that are meaningful
then you can extract out path of being
from all of that that's worthwhile and
Noble and helpful and productive and all
of those things and and so the book is a
description of of how you might do that
and but more importantly why right
couple of things are there that could be
this is one of those issues that I
notice a lot with your interviews what
you just said right now if I were
looking to mince it I could say that
sexist against men why because he talked
about organizing your life this book
effectively is using a trait or teaching
people how to best enact a trait that is
actually pretty women have naturally
more than men organizational skills this
is something you talk about now if I
were looking to mince that as a radical
left is when they say well that's sexist
that's a byproduct of patriarchy you
extolling the virtues of organizational
capabilities could easily be turned as
so you're saying women are better than
men because they're more organized
here's here's where here's where you get
wrong because in the book y'all sucks
about how order is a stem of masculinity
in chaos from femininity so he does it
out okay
explain yourself haha are you teasing
poor Kathy Newman from channel 4 again
net well okay see that's that's what we
call a segue he was he was okay before
we get to Kathy Newman yeah um I'm
refraining here before we get to Kevin
your rise has obviously been meteoric
here this last year which will also be a
test of your northeast narcissism we'll
have to test those levels afterward
because often the kids right you know
right well I'm trying to keep that and
my existential terror is keeping the old
narcissism under control
well we'll test that later on in the
program but in the states large positive
feedback say
it seems in UK for people not named
Kathy Newman but Canada still a lot of
people there hate you what's interesting
to me is this is effectively a self-help
book I can't remember in my lifetime I'm
I'm sure someone will fact-check me here
I'm sure it's happened but certainly not
to this degree that a self-help book
has been met with so much backlash why
do you think that is because ultimately
what you are doing as someone who's
who's gone through the self authoring
program you are looking to help people
that's your goal well you know what I
took a stand against the radical
leftists that started about it's almost
18 months ago now and if you take a
stand against the radical leftists then
they immediately try to paint you as a
super villain of the right and so that's
just continuing in Canada or not with
everyone I mean I have many journalists
who are supporting what I'm doing in
Canada but it's definitely polarized and
like there was an article in Canada's
so-called national newspaper The Globe
and Mail this week which by the way is
failing dismal E as it moves forward
through time that really was a hip piece
and and it's an attempt by the people I
would say on the radical left or people
who are just misinformed to tar everyone
who dares to stand up to their
hypocritical and racist idiocy by making
the case that they're associated with
like far-right thinking which is just
preposterous it's first of all you don't
you don't have to be far-right to
dislike the radical left you just have
to be sensible and reasonable and not
full to the brim with resentment and
false what do you call that false
compassion so the problem is is if the
radical left admits that someone like me
actually happens to be reasonable then
they have to admit that reasonable
people can object to what they're doing
and then if reasonable people can object
to it then there's always the
possibility that there's something wrong
with it imagine that something wrong
with identity politics and identifying
people by race and ethnicity and and
construing the world as victim and
victimizer I would renowned I would
reduce that and just say imagine
something being wrong period
right and wrong you know that's just
amazing to me and you see that in some
interviews with you let me say one thing
if okay let's do a little test a little
bit of the narcissist in you this is
obviously the most viral interview I
think you've done with Kathy with Kathy
Newman
what would you say yes okay yes
definitely and it's one where I've seen
even leftists if you look at the
feedback saying okay this is an example
of someone who I disagree with but this
person is reasonable the feedback on the
Kathy Newman interview is almost
entirely positive would you say that's a
compared with other interviews that were
seen as more polarizing when you say
that's a relatively accurate assessment
yeah the only exception would be that
there was a flurry of newspaper articles
after the interview came out claiming
that Kathy Newman was victimized by my
evil army of trolls because I seem to
apparently have an evil army of five
million trolls yes which is a lot of
trolls you know at some point you start
wondering if the trolls are just normal
people yeah but yes I would say that the
apart from the press and there was a lot
they were they want people to think you
have direct access to Jim Henson's
Creature Shop and you're sending them
out yeah it's exactly and well in The
Guardian claim and Channel four as well
that they had to bring in the police to
do a security analysis and and you can
bring in the police under any
circumstances doesn't mean that the
threats are credible and I don't think
they produced any evidence whatsoever
that the threats the threats so-called
were credible but yes I would say
overwhelmingly the consensus is that
Kathy Newman conducted that interview in
a highly biased ideologically rigid
confrontational and inappropriate manner
okay good so I just want to make sure
that we recap this so your most viral
interview and certainly the feedback
among amongst viewers and listeners as
positive as we've seen this year let's
kind of separate the media from it a
little bit because you know yeah when
it's more wrong so yeah so I think a big
question here is you know why is that
why were you so successful at this and
obviously you're wildly successful so by
the way take this or leave it and I am
not at all assuming that four people
hold your comments and I know anything
more than Jordan Pederson on any given
topic he's a doctor I'm not got it what
I will say is this as an intellectual as
kind of an existentialist and you've
talked about this sometimes you can be
almost too smart for your own good
what I think you did with this interview
so well certainly I would say more
perfectly than I've seen in any other
interview is this this form of I've
talked about a pattern disruption in
sometimes you'll you'll wax on sometimes
which is in a way that's very
intelligent but the viewer may not
necessarily directly correlate it to a
point I think what you do with Kathy new
one that was so effective is you asked a
follow-up question
you made her clarify her questions which
showcased them as absurd and you lasered
in on an answer better than I think I've
ever seen you do not that you haven't
done it well but you did it with every
question here it was almost like a boxer
just coming back making her overreach
and straight down the pipe that's what I
saw would you say maybe that's why
didn't know oh there he is yeah it was
fortunate to have handled that interview
properly I think what clued me in I
think very rapidly was when we when I
first sat down with her in front of the
cameras before they were running she was
very friendly and engaging and chirpy
and and you know I thought that we were
actually going to have a conversation
because that's what we were having
before the cameras rolled but as soon as
the cameras went on it was like she was
a completely different person and what
happened in some sense was that I I the
clinical psychologist in me turned on
because that was such a dramatic shift
in character I thought oh there's
something strange going on here and so I
got really detached from the interview
now I not completely detached because it
was still a high-pressure situation I
would say but I started just to watch
what she was doing instead of taking it
personally and what I realized almost
immediately was that the person she was
talking to bore virtually no resemblance
to me and so it was hard to take it
personally you know like if people come
after you with attacks let's say or
insults or or they're after your
character and they and they cut close to
the bone well that's one thing but if
they come at you with all sorts of
accusations that really bear no
relationship whatsoever to either what
you think or what you said
then it's easier to be detached and I've
also been trying hard to maintain a
sense of humor through everything that's
happened over the last 18 months and
that's been difficult
partly because I've had very serious
health problems and of course that makes
having a sense of humor difficult but
also because in many situations I had a
lot on the line and wasn't sure how it
was going to go but my sense of humor
has returned and although I don't know
if you can tell that in this interview
yet but it has there's this ironic
because usually in this this is one of
the few places people go Jordan Peterson
laughing but I'm just facet I wanted to
get to this you seem more relaxed yeah
you seem more relaxed in the interview
flip more I hate to use word but use
this a lot in in combat sports more
fluid you know you just you were able to
take what she gave you and every time
return it back tenfold and and it's
almost like you know that analogy you're
a tiger who kind of has to bleed a
little bit before you're in the fight
I've noticed that when you're with
friendly people there's no time
constraint you have so much room to you
know expand upon an idea sometimes being
framed in by someone else who's
confrontational might bring out the best
in you and I think we saw that it was
formidable yeah well it's a lot easier
to have a sense of humor when you're not
feeling 3/4 dead right yeah so you know
my health is back I'm in pretty good
shape again and so it's a lot easier to
be sharp as well and to pay attention to
what's going on but also to to do to
have a bit of a lighter touch and I've
always struggled with that with the
material I deal with because it's so
serious you know I mean totalitarianism
an atrocity is what I've been studying
for 30 years and it doesn't really get
any darker than that but I do know that
even despite the fact that that what I
study is very dark and and I suppose
some of the things I talk about is very
dark too that the humor is just
unbelievably necessary and I think I was
able to keep a lighter touch in that at
an interview and to laugh a little bit
especially at the absurdity of it
because it just became well I think the
reason that it went viral is because the
interview became its own parody yeah
like she could have what what should
have happened likely was that she should
have gone after me like
I thought afterwards I thought that was
like being mauled by 20 miniature
pitbulls and I was sure that I was sure
the channel 4 was going to edit that and
cut it up so that I would look like an
absolute monster and I guess they did
that to some degree with regards to what
they broadcast and also what they put
put on their Facebook page but they put
the whole interview up on YouTube which
I actually think you know you could say
well more power to them and fairness but
I actually think they did that out of
straight naivety I don't think they had
any idea whatsoever what that interview
actually looked like to the outside
world the shell shocked by the response
I really believe that I have some inside
information from channel 4 and I've been
following people's reaction to it like I
invited Kathy Newman to do another
interview
no because I suit through a back door
gentleman I said look like why don't we
basically make this right instead of it
ending this way because you've taken a
lot of flack for this why don't we
actually sit down and have it a talk and
then that'll work out fine and she said
something like well I need to let this
die down and rethink it but I don't
understand what all the fuss is about I
thought the interview went very well
well I think whoever's in charge of
their YouTube account probably not a big
Kathy Newman fan and uploads it access
to YouTube that's fascinating so she
didn't take you up on it
I mean you know yeah I think there is
some naivete there but it's interesting
that they they uploaded that entirety
what we had that with Sky News remember
that I'm not gay Joe you were there one
time and there were some producers there
who didn't like one of their hosts but
they brought me on and you could tell
that's how I got my gig at Fox News and
that's how I got my spots at CNN you
know as a young kid was just a comedian
even have the show back then it was just
kind of kind of a lamb for the slaughter
and I did all right you know it's like
they set me in front of Alan Combs and I
did okay and then they kept bringing me
back I don't think they always
necessarily expect it and like you said
they're out of touch they she may have
thought that she did really well in that
interview one thing that I often do and
I think we've talked about this to
prepare for debates to prepare for
conversations or even just to see kind
of where I stack up against great
thinkers and you would be certainly in
today's sort of great thinker Mount
Rushmore I would say is all what the
first time
watch an interview I'll watch the Kathy
Newman portion and pause it before I
hear your response and I respond as
though it's in real-time I'll do this
with Bill Maher I'll do it with I don't
know Don Lemon I'll do it with Kathy
Newman just to see how I would respond
so it's as close to a live simulation as
possible one thing that you handled
superbly it was very different I noticed
from where I took this when she said
well hold on a second I'm talking about
the transgender law in Canada
she said why does your freedom of speech
Trump their right to not be offended and
I just paused it and my answer was there
is no right to not be offended but that
way and yours was actually I thought oh
this might play against him I thought it
was a little too intellectual but it
actually drew her into a firefight to
where you ultimately said gotcha you
said well think about it you need to
have the right to be offensive because
you need to have the right to dagan to
offend me and that's absolutely
something you should be doing and you
turned it in a personal analogy and
telling her giving her more free rein
and I think she was caught off guard by
that that was handled really well but
she was because it was so the thing is
it was so patently obvious by that point
that she was doing everything she
possibly could to make me uncomfortable
she knew it I knew it the viewers knew
it there was no doubt about it and it
was easy just to point to that and then
to say well perhaps that's what you
should be doing at least you certainly
have the right to do that right that
offense argument like we can break that
down a little bit because that's
worthwhile it's like okay you don't have
the right to say anything that offends
someone else it hurts their feelings
okay what if you're talking to a
thousand people you don't have the right
to say anything that's going to offend
any one of those thousands of people
which basically means you do not have
the right to say anything at all because
in a group of a thousand people people
virtually anything you say will be
regarded as offensive by at least one
person even if it's merely a consequence
of the fact that they're misinterpreting
you and so really the the right the
absence of the right to offend is
absence of the right to speak at all
right and that just seems so
self-evident all you have to do is think
about it and if it's not a thousand
people one well what if you're Kathy
Newman and you're talking to a million
people like she
defending people non-stop and she has to
know I know it she doesn't understand it
though she she thinks because I think
this is important she sees intent as the
ultimate kind of value there what
Trump's the action is the intent her
intent isn't to offend and she ascribes
intent to you your intention was to
offend she even went as far as saying
that you know to harm transgender people
I think in her eyes it's okay for her to
speak as long as she's not intending to
hurt anyone's feelings and people like
you know your feelings don't don't
matter so much to her there's also a
misinterpretation of my stats because my
stance had very little initially to do
with transgender people the the whole
issue of transgender phobia let's say is
that the backlash from the radical
leftist what I said was that I would not
use words that the government was
compelling me to say the fact that they
happened hypothetically to be about
transgender people was just a sideshow
in some sense yeah not that their
concerns were irrelevant but that wasn't
the point if if all this was was about
transgender pronouns it would have
disappeared well a year ago it would
have disappeared immediately that that's
not the issue at all and everyone knows
it
issue really is that there's a culture
war going on and the radical leftists
are trying to push an agenda on everyone
and they're doing it quite effectively
and I said that I wasn't going to play I
said specifically that I would not allow
the radical leftists to define the
linguistic territory right that was
correct and and it's the right thing to
do because if you well look if the law
radical leftists define the linguistic
territory and the game we start playing
is identity politics right so it's every
group against every other group in a war
against all and that there's no real
communication between the groups
possible and its victim and victimizer
narrative and that's the way of the
world then one of the things that does
instantly is open the door to the
identitarian right who will say ok no
problem you can define the game its
identity politics I'm white I'm white
and male let's say and I'm not gonna
play to lose I'm gonna bloody well play
to win
because that's what the right-wing
identitarian z' will do right and and
that's well both of the whole for me the
response to that is let's just not play
that game right you know in The Globe
and Mail wrote an article I think I
mentioned this where the headline was
something about me being an angry white
male and I thought I don't really care
what you guys say about me I like it
bothers me or it doesn't bother me or or
bring it on or the or the what would you
say the controversy is useful or like
there's lots of ways of interpreting it
I'd rather people didn't attack me for
things that were untrue although it's
actually kind of a relief it's better
than to be attacked for things that are
true you know it's some sense but I
couldn't believe that our national
newspaper was so god dumb that they
would title a article with a racial
epithet you know it's like angry white
men I see so this is what we're gonna do
in Canada is it we're gonna start having
this discussion about these discussions
and we're going to label them with race
and that's how we're gonna make Canada
which is already a very peaceful country
much more peaceful that's your that's
your solution you morons well you know
it's funny because that's what she
accuses you doing she goes you know
you're trying to stir it up a bit you're
trying to get men devoid people men and
women and Tran that's what she said
about you and then they go along with
headlines like angry white male again
it's about intent they go angry white
male or patriarchal male well it doesn't
matter if this offends anybody because I
didn't intend to so it's okay
publish print they don't see that they
see you is trying to divide and conquer
through truth and that's what's most
concerning to me I'm not playing
identity politics games like I'm not
going to view the world through the lens
of your group identity right that that
means just stepping outside of that game
completely and that is what I did with
rules for life like there's a little bit
of political content in it in Chapter
eleven rule 11 which is don't bother
children when you're escaped when
they're skateboarding and it's a it's a
somewhat of a tribe against the idea
that boys should be socialized like
girls which i think is an appalling an
absolutely appalling idea and i also
think it's an idea for which there is
absolutely no justification
in the psychological literature so I
kind of touched on politics there but
more because politics has invaded a
sphere it should stay the hell out of
right but the rest of the book is a book
about individual responsibility as an
antidote in some sense to the tragedy
and malevolence of life hold on a second
Austin I'm gonna interrupt there really
quickly do you see why you don't you
just said your book is in and of itself
seen as political based on what you just
said you must see this it's about the
power of the individual which is of
course you're placing the power of the
individual the influence of the I guess
or the power of the individual over
their own destiny over the importance of
the collective and that is why leftists
will always see it as political there's
no way out of it you just have to
embrace it because it's about the
collective the reason that I think it's
it is political but it's more than
political and that's the case that I
make in the book it's that the idea that
the individual should be sovereign is
not a political idea right it's a
philosophical idea it's actually a
theological idea it's actually the
fundamental theological idea and that's
actually the level at which this battle
has to be far because it is in some
sense a battle between the idea that the
collective is sovereign versus the idea
that the individual is sovereign and the
great idea of the West
more than any other cultural group I
would say especially the articulated
idea is that even for the sake of the
group the individual has to be sovereign
because the individual is the force that
revitalizes the group when it becomes
hidebound and and static and I think the
evidence for that is overwhelming I
think the West got that right like we
got some things right that sovereignty
of the individual is the most important
one the absolute necessity for freedom
of expression that's another thing we
got right we got the idea of private
property right conjoined with the notion
that you also have responsibility to
your property so that you Shepherd it
and use it properiy is it properly these
are not political ideas there they are
because they find expression in the
political realm but they're rooted in
something far deeper than mere
opinionated politics and twelve rules
for life explains why that is right
think the evidence is clear from from
neurobiology from neuroscience from
evolutionary psychology from mythology
from comparative literature and I talked
about all that in the book it's like the
pattern are from game theory from
economic theory like the evidence is
compiling from multiple disciplines
simultaneously that there is a central
ethic that drives productive well let's
say that helps you be healthy as an
individual that drives positive
relationships between you and your
intimate partner that's that's your
family's trait that works good for the
community all of that there's an ethic
that does all of that and it's not
merely an arbitrary political opinion I
believe that that's wrong that's why the
post modernists are wrong enough of them
they are wrong right well and that's
that's interesting one thing I also
notice with your Kathy Newman interview
and the reason I think the left sees you
as such a political threat is um it
seems it's a less and less we have when
people talk about common ground
foundational truths upon which we agree
for example you sing men and women are
fundamentally different they want
different things there used to be a
point where even feminists could say
well yeah of course but we believe that
the constraints of sassette but and then
you go down the path and how we don't
even agree on that and you were on Joe
Rogan show the same day actually I was
so he caught a lot of flack for that it
was now becoming a best I thought it was
the coming of the Fourth Reich for them
it's a certain foundational truths that
okay we were talking about you don't put
children on puberty blockers regardless
of how you feel about the trans issue
sanity you don't put him on puberty
blockers that's not a foundational truth
we can even agree upon anymore and
that's what I was noticing and why I
thought you were so affected with Kathy
Newman you would just say well well why
is that when she would say is not
equality of the genders or of the sexes
sorry important and you asked well why
and define it and she wasn't able to
define it because she didn't even
understand her own premise because we
don't have foundational truths that we
agree upon anymore and here's something
absolutely comical that happened in the
last two weeks so you remember James
d'amour the engineer that got fired at
Google yes he wrote a memo saying poor
James hey he's an engineer and so he
went to a diversity seminar
and the diversity seminar people asked
for feedback and James d'amour is an
engineer and so he thought oh they want
feedback and because he's a good
engineer he thought oh they want
intelligent carefully thought through
thoughtful feedback yeah so that's what
he provided them with and then they
ignored it completely and he thought
well they wanted feeb why they ignore it
so then he posted it on an internal memo
board which people at Google do all the
time to see if he could get some
discussion going there and then that was
leaked it wasn't like James the more
planned this he was just doing what a
non-political engineer would do when
someone asked them for feedback someone
who might be a little on the spectrum as
many engineers are yes right oh I think
we overlords very therefore you know
are we there yes we're there sorry go
ahead we just said we left with with
engineers in the spectrum and I think
you had something funny I apologize okay
well so the CEO of Google came out and
said he he wasn't sorry that he fired
James tomorrow and then he had a little
discussion with the CEO of YouTube and
she ended up saying that what women
don't really like the geeky sort of jobs
that characterize Silicon Valley and I
thought God how can you do that that
exact that's exactly it's exactly what
tomorrow was talking about exactly that
and you know it is the case that the
biggest difference the biggest
psychrometric difference between men and
women is actually in what they're
interested in and so women tilt towards
interest in people and men tilt towards
interest in things and that's most
pronounced in the scandinavian countries
where most has been done to level the
gender playing field and you know the
people i talk to about this
to talk to a new york I think it was New
York Magazine reporter and he said well
isn't that pseudoscience and I thought
no
[Laughter]
well is that among serious scientists
especially the ones that are
biologically oriented this isn't even
debatable we settled this back in like
1982
you know Steve Pinker wrote a book a
while back called the blank slate where
he made a case that people had a
biological name sure and we weren't just
socio-cultural creations and I read that
book and I thought Jesus Steve I don't
know why you wrote this book it's like
everyone knows this it's like that was
done in the 1980s right but I didn't
understand at that point that there was
this tremendous radical leftist doc
clash against the idea that human beings
have a biological nature well there is
there's no backlash against biology
period the most sexist people I would
have to be biologists I mean you know
and it doesn't work in the medical field
ironically dominated by women but for
example you know when you're talking
about the gold standard for trials when
you're talking bout double-blind
placebo-controlled clinical trials right
the placebo means okay we have a
controlled group and often if you're
trying to study a new substance right if
you're trying to clear medicine with the
FDA you have to compare it to a
substance that has predictable
biological results meaning okay we're
gonna use a substance where we know
exactly how this affects let's say the
liver or the kidneys or what the
half-life is and we're going to compare
this new substance and it's biological
reactivity within the body so in other
words at some point you have to
determine truthfully what an
establishing substance does to the body
to know how to use it as a comparison
we're now saying we'll hold on a second
maybe I don't think that a
semi-different does that in the body but
it does know you know that's where we
are yeah it's certainly possible in the
post modernists are doing this to take
science apart right to the core and to
think about it just as another ideology
right and the problem with that is that
the post modernists don't act that way
because they use their cell phones and
there's a and they're super good you
know their desktop supercomputers which
rely on the objective reality of quantum
mechanics and they swallow that without
a second thought
so they act out their belief that
science is something that transcends
mirror ideology but they won't allow
that entry into their ideological claims
one of the things I do in 12 rules for
life and new
went after me a little bit about this
because she thought she might have some
fun with my writing about lobsters you
know about how absurd was comparing
human beings to lobsters right um it's
actually not that absurd in many ways
which I and I make that case in 12 in
the first chapter but by the way anyone
who knows anything about psychiatry
knows a lobsters thing I've heard I
heard about that years ago and remember
asking my saying what the hell does a
lobster on an antidepressant look like
because that's hilarious the first time
you hear about it but it's well known in
the psychiatric community so Kathleen
was just an idiot continued yeah yeah
well so you know there's this idea that
the radical left is put forth there's a
couple of ideas they put forth apart
from the fact that group identity should
be the paramount virtue that are also
just wrong so here's one inequality is
caused by capitalism that's wrong so
here's some evidence the same law the
same formulas that govern the
distribution of wealth in a society
govern the mass of stars the size of
cities and the heights of trees in
jungles now you can blame the latter
three on capitalism right there's
something deeper at work this proclivity
towards in an unequal distribution of
resources in something like a powerful
natural law and it does threaten the
integrity of societies and we don't know
what to do about it but it isn't the
fault of capitalism and okay next issue
the patriarchy the hierarchy so the
patriarchal hierarchy is a consequence
of Eurocentric fellow Co centric
capitalist domination and that's not the
real se state of nature okay that's
wrong there's beaten hierarchies for 350
million years that's why I use the
lobsters as an example is that and the
mechanisms that we that that we use
neurobiologically to govern our emotions
and govern our posture and determine our
self esteem and all of that are akin to
the mechanisms that lobsters use and
lobsters have been around since before
there were trees and so the hierarchy is
older than trees right it's not a
socio-cultural construct well it's wrong
read that to say that it's wrong to put
in
to describe inequality as a consequence
of capitalism it's wrong to assume that
people's group identities should be
superordinate to their individual
entities identities it's wrong that
there's an infinite number of valid
interpretations of the world those are
all postmodern claims right they're all
wrong it's done we're done with one
thing by the way I should have prefaced
this you talked about that sort of
posture and self-esteem the neuro
chemistry of lobsters are so similar to
human that they've actually administered
antidepressant psychiatric medication to
lobster Larry so with very similar
effects it is hysterical the first time
you hear about it let me add two things
here I'd like to kind of get before we
get to the lobster thing because that's
gonna be the majority of this interview
I'm not going to lie about it I just
find it hysterical but you just
mentioned okay that we cannot blame
inequality on capitalism so I think a
big part of if you look it's whether
it's socialism whether it's communism
whether it's free enterprise capitalism
right these at a point where mechanism
is designed to help us cope with or help
us to best frame in sort of the essence
of a human being right we see it as
something for example if you see
socialism the reason socialism exists is
because people inherently recognize that
inequality exists not as the byproduct
of socialism but socialism is a design
solution for that so I would follow that
up with a bike hate to be political with
it but this is entirely accurate okay we
know that regardless of the society
anywhere throughout history there has
been inequality has there been a single
system in the history of man that has
pulled more people out of poverty than
modern westernized free enterprise the
interests not only know it's so clearly
know that it's just it's almost
miraculous like there have been more
people lifted out of poverty in the last
15 years than were lifted out of poverty
in the entire history of mankind before
that like not only are people being
lifted out of poverty they're being
lifted out at a rate that is actually
inconceivable we can actually be done
with extreme poverty except for that
that's caused by cataclysmic events we
could be done with that in ten years and
so and that is just and that's why
they've shifted to inequality right
because well here's a standard poverty
but hold on there's a bigger gap yeah
but let's say the pie was 1 million
dollars
and you had 50% of it but now the pie is
5 billion dollars and you have 20% of it
you're still better off and that's why
they shift the goalposts well so we we
could make this argument technical in
some say said that we could say look you
need a certain number of units of
inequality to produce a certain number
of units of wealth mm-hmm ok so no
inequality no wealth bad idea everyone
starves
but then there's a limit on the other
side which is if the inequality gets too
extreme even if no one's starving the
society is going to destabilize it sure
and I think the evidence for that is
clear so then we have a problem which is
ok inequality tends to emerge of its own
accord in all sorts of different domains
so it emerges among sports among
athletes right because if you look at
the distribution of athletic prowess it
follows the same purrito distribution
that wealth distribution does it happens
for recording artists this happens for
artists it happens for authors it just
happens everywhere
ok so we might say what we don't want to
let the inequality get so extreme that
society starts to destabilize so we have
to figure out how to mitigate the the
gap but then we can have an intelligent
conversation about how to develop
multiple strategies to mitigate that gap
and see which one's work and mere
shoveling money to the bottom end of the
distribution like shoveling money today
to the what do you call that the it's
the it's the lower class but it's that
it's the lower class people that
Theodore Dalrymple write about the
people that are outside the system
completely if you give a cocaine addict
money if you give an alcohol addicted
cocaine addict money he'll just die it's
a really bad solution right because
he'll just go out on a binge and he'll
spend all his money and he'll die and
there's lots of people at the bottom of
the heap
whose lives are so absolutely
dysregulated that merely providing them
with money will not help them so it's
not the right solution now and we do
have serious problems here too because
we're also setting up a situation
where most of the people who are on the
low end of the inequality distribution
also have low cognitive function and
that's going to be a worse and worse
problem as the machines take over our
jobs they're going to start taking over
the jobs for people who have lower IQs
first well obviously how could it be any
other way but that's actually a really
big problem we don't know how to deal
with it but we could have an intelligent
discussion about that without getting
all identity politics about it you know
right and if the left nothing which I
hope they do then they'd stop playing
identity politics and start standing up
for the dispossessed again right which
is what they should be doing not to
mention the the moral reprehensibility
of simply stealing from someone to give
it to someone else that's just it's just
wrong at a certain point if say this is
theft that's not only a financial issue
that's a moral issue but interesting
like you talked about we have no problem
with that we in sports which by the way
is also the byproduct of free enterprise
if you look at professional sports
leagues I guess we need to redistribute
the jamaicans fast-twitch muscle fibers
and 100-meter dash just let's let's
let's fine-tune our drafting techniques
here's one thing do you still as a
psychologist you still practice like do
you still see basket cases or you not
have time for that I don't I stopped my
clinical practice last February because
I got swamped sure and one of the things
that you can't do as a clinical
psychologist is be distracted so when I
do an hour of therapy with someone I
like to give them 100% of my attention
because we're talking about very crucial
things past present and future and
unless I'm concentrating a hundred
percent and also have enough additional
mental capacity during the week to be
thinking about my clients and what
they're going through and to be
available then I risk making a mistake
and so I pulled out of my clinical
practice last February partly because of
health concerns but also partly because
my life got too complicated and I
haven't picked it back up I think it's
very noble of you because you don't want
to be distracted as I did what did he
reach out to anyone Oh Shh I had a
suicide letter and I forgot to submit it
yeah
so obviously this could exactly what's
no joke so you have to really be careful
about that yeah I just made a joke about
anyway
so let me ask you what we're talking
preciate it you talked about the lobster
shoulders back you know and you talked
about sort of this this a lot of people
would do they do well to take on a more
combative nature in other words to sort
of you talk about this fight for their
territory earning courageous courageous
okay but it's courageous and vulnerable
at the same time yes well that it was
going to be my follow-up question
because I I wonder this in your practice
and as someone who is who is who
regularly still does counseling I think
everyone should do it to some degree
certainly if you're married you have
different people come into your
practices how do you sort of apply this
life principle to let's say someone who
might come in like a beaten puppy
someone who's meek someone who's slumped
over and recognize the difference and
how would you coach them versus someone
who comes in headstrong cocky and is
already too combative because it seems
like you could be given somebody you
know some some arms that some people
probably don't need well a lot of so in
the first case someone who's beaten down
and being bullied say maybe their whole
life a lot of what I do with them is
listened you know and walk through like
I had a client a while back who had been
bullied so badly in high school that she
had a psychotic episode yeah and so she
was so broken when she first saw me that
it was just beyond belief like she could
barely talk and she was having visual
hallucinations and it was really really
really bad and I just let her talk for
about three months I just listened to
welcome it happened to abstraction in
her speech and we we wrote down what
happened to her and made it coherent and
talked about malevolence a lot because
the kids who went after her we're really
doing it with vicious intent like they
were out to take her out and they did
and there was an ugly situation so a lot
of that's listening it's like okay what
happened to you who did it why were you
making yourself more vulnerable than he
needed to because you didn't have the
skills to defend yourself or see what
was happening or fight back all of that
then distracted eyes about
you could come up with an appropriate
defense against similar things in the
future because the purpose of memory
isn't to remember the purpose of memory
is to extract our wisdom from the past
so you don't repeat catastrophes in the
future and so if you help someone sort
through their memories especially of
terrible like sustained psychological
assault of that sort
then you arm them for the future and
that restores them to health and she got
much much better she was able to go back
to school and all of that and so thank
God for that and then with someone who's
most of the time Steven you don't see
the over confident types in therapy
because they're kind of narcissistic and
they never come for therapy but you do
see people now and then who are less
sophisticated in their disagreeable
attitude than they might be and usually
what you do with people like that has
helped them strategize more carefully
it's like okay you want to operate in
the world in a combat event competitive
manner fine let's see if we can turn
that into a sophisticated dance and
instead of a random flailing of fists
sure and so it isn't a matter of
inhibiting their aggression it's a
matter of helping them develop much more
sophisticated strategies for so maybe
someone is fairly combative and
explosive and they're mad at their boss
and because things aren't going the way
they should at work and now and then
they have a fit or they're resentful and
bitter well no that's both of those are
very bad strategies it's like okay what
are you upset about what do you want as
a solution can you possibly obtain this
in the current workplace or do you have
to look for another job what's your
strategy for moving forward and those
would be like conversations that
probably take about a year yeah right
because it's really complicated to come
up with a full life strategy for career
development for example although it's
unbelievably useful I mean it's
incredibly this time oh yeah most of the
time in my consulting practice because
my practice found the gamut from people
who were extraordinarily impaired in
almost every way to people who were
hyper competent and the some of the
people who came in for consulting and so
that would be career development and
life development planning
you know we tripled her in
come in three years by strategic but it
was like it was it was a sequence of
battles put inside a large-scale
strategies and now there's going to be
an army of people saying open up your
private practice I want to triple my
income dr. Peterson you promised you'd
make me more money well you know it's
interesting though do you start off
could the premise sort of in your book
you should start off with the idea of
listen more people would would benefit
from being able to sort of stand in the
pocket being able to be courageous so
obviously like we said there are two
different kinds of people the second
kind of person probably wouldn't see
counseling anyway probably wouldn't be
reading this book but do you write that
this is chapter one do you write it from
that point of view because you see that
as a more plaguing problem in today's
society timidity lack of confidence lack
of self esteem I don't know if it's
worse no I don't necessarily think it's
worse than it has been although the
stats for depression and anxiety among
young people are pretty do you think it
would be more prevalent than like the
cocky overconfident type of oh yeah
still yes it's definitely more prevalent
not oh for sure like ten to one okay I
would say yeah yeah and you know the
twelve rules for like life is as a call
not so much to be not anxious but to not
let anxiety stop you right that's the
thing and there's an explanation of why
it might stop you and an explanation of
why people become embittered and unhappy
and deceitful and resentful and all of
that as well so but yeah it's it's very
practical you know you were saying maybe
people would beat down my the doors of
my consulting practice to figure out how
to triple their income and I would say
well the first thing you want to do is
if that's your goal first of all you
want to decide if that's actually your
goal right because you if you're gonna
do that there's a bunch of other things
you can't do right because you just
can't do everything but let's say you
want to triple your income
okay well pick a time frame maybe it's
three to five years and then figure out
what the hell is wrong with you that's
stopping you from looking at other
opportunities well you have to get your
resume together and it can't have holes
in it and you have to have some
education you have to be you have to be
able to produce something that's a value
to other people you have to start being
resentful about competing in the work
place you have to be willing to
undergo endless interviews you have to
send out 50 resumes a week for two years
and assume that 99% of them will fail
you have to assume that you'll go to a
multiple interviews at most of the time
you won't get the job like it's a
grueling battle or you have to do a
podcast on local radio for years without
being paid a dime with under the under
this false presumption that someday it
might actually have a significant enough
viewership and listeners else you could
actually make a living to employ 15
people it might be a pride-swallowing
siege which I will never fully tell you
about for several years and it's true
yeah you know what I will tell you this
I'm going through that right now with
trying to improve my my relationships
and my marriage before we have children
oh we could have chillie probably be
better than most parents but I don't
want to be that dad who work 16 hours a
day and isn't there for my kids and
because I'm tired I get frustrated and
something that was really telling them
me and this really tucked me into bed
yes barely but don't but I do I find the
time I make the time priorities that's
also in his book dr. Jordan Peter C's
book is about making a plan I make a
plan and I have back passages to not get
yourself so one thing like with with my
marriage is like you said setting a plan
okay assessing yourself and something
that was very telling to me and a lot of
people seen as weakness marriage
counseling I think it's I highly
recommend it because almost every
stereotype about men and women you
realize it is true when you're in a
marriage the miscommunications that
occur the way you both read situations
and our counselor said listen anger from
a man from a husband to a wife is almost
never productive and a marriage he's
unusually anger is disguising some other
emotion it's usually either disguising
hurt or fear sitting with your wife it
will be more productive to be vulnerable
and remove the cloak of anger with her
you don't have to do it with everyone
but in the privacy of your marriage your
wife will respond better to
vulnerability so examine why you're
angry usually it's hurt or fear and
express that to your wife and that was a
breakthrough and I don't know if that's
that's the kind of thing that you have
to be honest with yourself before you
can come to a solution truth is at the
center of it
oh I think you will I talk a fair bit
about that and 12 rules about resentment
yes you know you have to consult your
resentment and and you find you
resentful about something okay why well
there's only two reasons the first
reason is that you're whiny and useless
and you should shut the hell up and grow
up yeah because like that's life and and
and and quit being such a twerp but yes
strong words having established that
you're not being a twerp and that
something is actually wrong that you
need to set right then you have to
figure out exactly what it is that's
wrong and you have to figure out exactly
what you would like to make that go away
like one of the best things you can do
in your marriage if you're arguing with
your spouse is actually tell them what
would minimally be satisfying you right
it's like I'm mad at you because you did
this it's like okay fine but no you need
something else it's like I think that
what's happening here is suboptimal and
if we did it this way which would
require only a little change that that
would be better and let's try that for a
week and then we can discuss it again
you know and so you have to make these
things concrete you know like maybe
you're having battles about frequency of
sexual interactions with your wife
because that's very common especially
once you have kids yeah it's like well
what's your minimal requirement a tip
make it so you it's like I know I want
you to be around when I need you it's
like oh yeah Jesus go away you have a
boner 24/7 that's not gonna happen
yeah same conversations not Kay Jarrett
has with his with his hand it's the
stranger so you sit on it for two
minutes it goes numb makes you feel
loved everyone needs affection no you're
you well one thing I will say though and
often within a marriage and that's why I
think marriage counseling is so
important because now you've added two
people first off don't date someone who
hasn't who hasn't sort of themselves out
don't marry someone who is in a constant
state of crisis and they could use this
book fix yourself first but then you
realize like we're talking about with
anger in a marriage it's usually not
actually stemming from your spouse
because you married them generally
speaking because you love them often
frustration is coming from these outside
circumstances which you tend to
channel in to the person he spend the
most amount of time with for example
yeah well you often don't know it right
because you go to work you get upset and
then you're all irritable and you don't
really even know why cuz right maybe ten
stupid things happen that day that you
haven't fully thought through and then
you come home and your wife says
something that's that rubs you the wrong
way and bang you're irritable as hell
and then you have a little discussion
you think well I think I'm mad at you
for saying this thing and then you think
it you think it through and you think oh
I'll wait a minute these ten things
happen at work oh yeah that's a
reflection of a deeper problem work that
I don't even really want to think about
and a lot of discussions between house
I'm damned this Canadian internet I
think he's still there dr. P husbands
and wives were left off on husbands
we're leaving on husbands and wives I
think he's there I can see his
good-lookin mug but I can't do the whole
cup now we're spending here now we're
still here wives husbands and wives
apologies it's your damn kanae they've
come for you and your internet yeah well
a lot of discussions between husbands
and wives that are combative are
actually discussions about what the
problem is rather than what the solution
is this is something that husbands
really don't understand well about
listening to their raps is the husband's
want to cut right to the chase and solve
the problem but the wives are trying to
figure out well wait a minute what's the
problem maybe it's this maybe it's that
there has to be a fair bit of wandering
in this conversation to even specify
what the problem is
cuz it's that once you know what the
problem is it's actually not that hard
to solve it usually but it's definitely
hard to identify the problem yeah and as
you talked about with some of your
female patients before often with wives
simply listening and not providing a
solution is the solution is validation
to emotions which isn't something that
computes with a lot of men usually
you're saying this miss and you want to
hear well maybe this is how yeah that's
the ticket and you go off any carrier
solution but often women are saying
something because they want you to
listen they go oh that's good I feel
better now these are things that you can
only know if you go in yourself and look
so well so one of the things that
happens when if you listen to someone
who has problems this is what they do
is they think okay I'm upset and here's
20 things that might be a problem and
then if you listen to them go through it
it's kind of painful especially if you
live with them because you think you
might be part of that you might be at
the core of all 20 of those problems you
know yes maybe you are but if you can be
patient and let the person lay out all
20 problems then the next thing they'll
do is they'll think oh wait a minute 18
of those aren't relevant here's the Ark
here's the one that's here's the one
that's important but they can't get to
the important one before wandering
through all the potential ones and so
sitting back and waiting
it's like you'd only let the person lay
all their cards on the table before they
can pick up the one that's relevant
right and that takes patience that's
really important yeah and if you want to
piss off your wife in a hurry have her
list 20 problems bothering her and say
18 of those aren't relevant and watch
her James amore yes exactly
wise words the book is 12 rules for life
it's selling like hotcakes
on Amazon I know we almost just scratch
the surface of chapter one chapter two
love to have you back soon and of course
the self authoring program the promo
code is Crowder where's the website for
the self offering program dr. Peterson
it's self authoring com takes about 15
minutes to fill out it'll give you a
very detailed description of your
personality you probably won't like it
that's many people yeah listen in it but
the good thing is if you are actually
examining yourself and this is why I
think you're seen as this crazy right
winger is this is a health self-help
book and so is a self offering based on
truth that's what we did the personality
test here on air people can go through
the archives and see us do that on air
it's not the secret that would be sort
of the antithesis to this the secret was
how rowdy what you want and it'll come
to you this is based on honest
assessment as well as now as you wish
you to be reality as it is your
shortcomings your attributes and how to
correct yourself I think everyone would
do well to read it dr. Peterson thank
you so much sir and I hope that this
meteoric rise continues just don't
become a narcissistic prick
I'll do my best now I've got people
keeping my feet on the ground alright
it's certainly not Candida though just
don't let the United States get to your
head we will be back at we'll be in
Virginia Tech tomorrow and dr. Peterson
back soon thank you so much sir we must
go
[Music]